good morning John it is Tuesday
September 1st which means what my butt
is vibrating my butt is my mom I'm gonna
talk to mom okay
hello love you too okay bye
I don't know what I'm gonna make my
video about today I thought maybe if it
has turned the camera on something would
have been absolutely figured I would
just talk to you about what's going on
like I told mom I was just in the record
studio I recorded three songs very
quickly I recorded a version of Alan and
Tom's can't which doesn't sound like me
at all it sounds like David Bowie jumped
into my body and like make me sing this
is how if you were the microphone and
that's how it would have looked and I
recorded meals are so half-assed in a
demolition derby song in studio version
here is Mueller so how has the mix lost
maybe a little bit of breath and dizzy I
was going this circle I got a few books
recently but I'm really excited about
I'm going to go try and find them okay
the third book was really hard for me to
find because it was actually propping up
my computer um being used to brought my
computer up so obviously I'm not reading
that one yet the first one is David
Burns bicycle Diaries which I got is a
review copy which I'm really excited
about because it's not officially out
yet I also got hotforwords this book
looks great because it's extremely
educational you know gerrymander I'm
sure you guys were looking at the words
at last book I got was geektastic which
is an anthology that has John Green in
it and I didn't even know until I was at
the store and I was reading through and
found it so yeah apparently John has
enough books now that he doesn't even
talk about them when he is in
anthologies but it's not just John Green
he's got all kinds of great geeks like
Cory Doctorow and Cecil Castelluccio and
David Levithan and scott westerfeld's
and Sara Zarr and Holly black I haven't
read anything but John can but John's is
very good also yesterday
I had a lady come to my house and take
pictures of me saw the newspaper okay
she wasn't actually just lady she was
actually a friend of mine but she does
work for the newspaper and they're doing
a story on her session proof jobs and
apparently I have one so I was like okay
so yeah I should I just like is this
what you want because I can do this well
here are some of them
there's a pirate
shot himself so he grabbed that dead
man's chest
see
you speak ass
and of course I'm going to ask you all
to vote on your favorite one not your
favorite one or two or seven or six or
five or four your favorite one in the
comments because the lady took the
pictures isn't sure which one of those
she should use and I get to use them
after their another story so I want to
know what your favorite one is if I'm
gonna use it for I don't know put it on
my Twitter page or something and just so
you know I don't have three computers I
just have the one in another monitor and
then she brought in another computer so
that it would look more epic I I'm
computer mac which honestly is how my
friends in Montana think of me like if
you asked any one of my friends what my
job was maybe like oh yeah Hank here he
works on computers I'm lucky when they
know what YouTube is but that's okay I
don't mind it's okay guys don't worry if
you're watching this and Who am I
kidding you're not books to buy you can
lever up to mini book and now I'm gonna
go to a baseball game John you will see
we can
who's this oh yeah
cuz this will happen